le sud fait écho à 20 km de la capitale
rivière salée en pleine fête avec nos
carnavaliers
dans cette commune se cachent nos super
héros il compte rester discrets tant qu
il fait encore jour elle aime bien être
incognito dans la vraie vie en fait
c'est mon carnaval même au carnaval
toujours inconnue tout eux ne cachent
pas leur joie ils célèbrent leur union
et pour que la fête soit belle
l'invité ce qu'on a prévenu plusieurs
éléphants
il ya du bon pied à tout pour tous les
goûts au fait
voilà il ya pour les végétariens ou une
invitation dans le sud en très peu de
temps
rivière salée prend de l'envol des cours
laisse l'espace thigpen j'abandonne
[Musique]
ils ont commencé par une magnifique
toute la parade finalement remporté un
franc succès et comme ce n'est qu'une
fois par an alors autant profiter
jusqu'au bout de laine
la belge suit ouais pourquoi pas profité
autant profiter c'est alors qu'après
japon allait bien le zoo avait apprécié
déjà belle ambiance le l'être ensemble
s'amusait bien relâché toute agression
ça fait de l'animation en fait on va
dire dans la ville et puis les enfants
aiment ça et de c'est coloré c'est
festif ça fait du bien par les sorties
cours
ce n'est pas tous les jours que les
communes du sud peuvent accueillir une
telle parade
alors pour le plaisir on fait durer le
spectacle pour que le festi sud raisonne
sur toute l'île
[Musique]